[Music]
what do you make of this Alicia Keys was
she making a big deal about not wearing
makeup are you wearing more makeup and
she's at this point I were very little
makeup I joked around so she's by the
way so great she was putting on a little
bit of makeup but it was like I was like
oh yeah Alicia doesn't wear makeup and
she's like I do what the [ __ ] I want
oh really I'm like I love you so much we
had going on the show you had told me
that Blake Shelton would be with Gwen
Stefani I would those you got your
[ __ ] money yeah I didn't see that
coming
but it's so wrong that it's right is
wrong it's super crazy like you think
yourself we're sitting these chairs and
you're like they're having sex
it is weird it's weird it's like oh it's
a dynamic shift aren't you glad your
wife is an on-set I mean click at least
you have a little break from each other
which is kind of hot yeah I mean like I
have a strangely like good situation
with my wife were like I just I really
like hanging out with her like as much
ha ha ha T ha ha t even her name I tell
you I do I do
literally he said to me once was super
funny I say to her all the time and you
did at some Behati got some behind some
behind I tell her that outfit I dated a
girl named Bo ugly